you know last time you guys [ __ ]  things up pretty bad we were kind of  horsing around last time you were i want  to apologize today we'll be much more on  our shift and professional yeah oh  really well yeah yeah what you said yeah  i believe that okay cool i brought my  own personal selection of knives for you  guys which one do you like i like josh  which one do you like better  i can't tell you that just say it  probably this one dips  all right there you go there's your jar  put the goggles on and see if you can  get that undone by the way uh the  previous knives dull these are these  will not forgive these knives are  unrelentless  oh good all right sorry  ah  completely bent nine degrees  damn cody oh sorry no i don't do it  you're being very quiet